noch erstaunliches ist nur noch dass die
großen Fernsehanstalten alle voran ARD
und ZDF die das Thema bis jetzt gemieden
haben jeden Tag Berichte senden über
Folgeschäden von Corona oder von der
corona-impfung da bewegt sich was im
Lande das ist kein Tab mehr das wird
nicht mehr den Querdenkern und den
leugnen überlassen es ist was los und
Lauterbach ist natürlich ein wunderbares
Beispiel das müsste Aufnahme in
Schulbüchern finden für ein
fehlgeleitetes Projektmanagement
er hat sehr viel für seine eigene
Karriere getan unserer Kollegin elke
bodeneras hat das vor zwei Tagen in der
Welt beschrieben und zwar wir sein
Lebenslauf gefälscht hat wir eine
falsche Entscheidung nach der anderen
getroffen hat sich dafür nicht
entschuldigt hat wir dann bei einer
falschen Aussage erwischt wurde und dann
sagt er ja das war nur versehentlich das
war nur die Flüchtigkeit nein dieses
versehen ist bei Lauterbach wirklich ein
systemwirkungen war das absolut
beispielhaft der trat lange damit auf
dass es gar keine Nebenwirkungen gibt
und das allein ist schon völlig absolut
bei jedem neuen Präparat gibt es
Wirkungen jeder Impfung Nebenwirkungen
das ist ja ganz normal
bestreiten das zu viel Alkohol so die
Sinne benebelt nein und dann hat er
eingeräumt es gibt schon Nebenwirkungen
und der letzte Stand der Dinge auf ein
paar Tagen ist
es gibt minimale Nebenwirkungen und dann
nannte auch eine Zahl und da bin ich
aufgeschreckt er sagte bei einer von
10.000 Impfungen kann es zu einer
Nebenwirkung kommen und auf dem ersten
Blick im ersten Moment war ich
beeindruck eins von 10.000 das ist
wirklich nichts nicht wahr aber dann
habe ich in einem Beispiel gesucht du
hast doch vielleicht etwas bedeutet eins
zu 10.000 übrigens in der gewöhnlichen
Pharmaforschung ins 1 zu 100.000 Schrein
relativ hohe Maßstab aber hier was eins
zu zehn ich habe nachgeguckt wie viele
Flugbewegungen ist in Deutschland pro
Tag gibt Flugbewegungen haben noch zwei
entscheidende fassen die Landung und den
Staat dabei verunglücken passieren die
meisten Unglücke die passieren selten
stürzt ein Flugzeug direkt auf das
Ministerium von der Lauterbach ab das
ist noch nicht vorgekommen
also bei 8.000 Flugbewegungen haben sie
bescheiden gerechnet 12 bis 16.000
Starts und Landungen also gehen wir mal
von 10.000 aus das würde ungefähr dem
der Zahl der Impfschäden entsprechend
von 10.000 Impfungen ein Schaden nehmen
wir an von 10.000 Starts und Landungen
würde ein Flugzeug pro Tag
abschmieren ein Flugzeug von 10.000
Staats- und Landungen pro Tag glauben
sie dann wieder noch jemand überhaupt
sich ins Flugzeug setzen wenn jeden Tag
ein Flugzeug abschmiert und glauben Sie
irgendein Lufthansa Mitarbeiter hätte
den Mut und zu erklären es ist doch nur
eins zu zehntausend da kommt es nicht
drauf an ja genau das hat Lauterbach
gemacht
10000 ist tot oder nach der Impfung das
müssen wir hier einmal festhalten nein
nein das ist nicht tot aber wenn Sie die
aktuellen Berichte sehen es sind Leute
mit schweren Schäden Leute die nicht
arbeiten können Leute die
wortfindungsprob
immer haben sich nicht zurechtfinden
können und wahrscheinlich gibt es auch
einige Todesfälle aber wissen Sie bei
wie ist das Zeug das schwangere Frauen
kontergarten untergegangen bei konnte
Gang glaube ich gab es fünf oder 600
Fälle es war rechnerisch wenig aber
natürlich 500 Katastrophen und 500
Rahmen und hier haben wir tausende von
Leute wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen
dass zwei g gab in Deutschland und viele
auch gezwungen wurden vor allem auch bei
der Bundeswehr nein das ganze was wir
erlebt haben war wirklich die
Generalprobe wie ein großen Notstand und
das Motto darüber war mal gucken wie
weit wir gehen können bevor die Leute
sich dagegen erheben und es hat ja
geklappt es hat ja geklappt es hat auch
geholfen die berühmte deutsche Kultur
die viel stärker ausgeprägte das ist die
Willkommenskultur neu zu entfachen jetzt
gibt es eine Initiative der Deutschen
Umwelthilfe die ich ohnehin wahnsinnig
schätze wenn sie gebrannter arbeiten
würde würde sie sich noch mehr schätzen
die Deutsche Umwelthilfe fordert jetzt
zu der Nutzung auf wenn Autos auf
Bürgersteig parken sollen die Anrainer
hingehen fotografieren und der Polizei
bescheid sagen gut ich ärgere mich auch
über Autos auf dem Park auf dem
Bürgersteig aber das ist doch nicht die
Art Leute zu benutzen beim
corona-komplex bleiben also eigentlich
fordern Sie wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe die Aufarbeitung und den
Rücktritt von Karl Lauterbach lieber
umgekehrt ersten Rücktritt von Karl
lauter
aber genau das sind wir vergessen jetzt
das Lauterbach zudem ich meine eigene
Meinung habe aber natürlich erst seit
einem Jahr das wären ihren sparen das
ganze mit verbrochen hat natürlich es
geht ja mir ist das zu eingeschränkt
wenn wir über Corona reden dann und die
Maßnahmen dann finde ich es
richtig dass man eine Lauterbach
Formulierung es gäbe keine impfen
nebenschäden war immer falsch das weiß
man eigentlich auch nein Leute nicht
heißt aber ja nicht dass man sich nicht
hätte impfen lassen sollen jedenfalls
heißt es nicht für mich aber der wunde
Punkt den ich habe in der Sache ist wir
haben ganz andere Dinge aufzuarbeiten es
ist nicht nur eine Dehnung entfernten
Republik geworden es ist ja auch eine
Republik die die die alle
Freiheitsrechte genommen hat ohne das
wirklich von dir begründen zu können
also haben wir das schon vergessen dass
man in Bayern nicht vollkommen Recht auf
der Parkbank sitzen durfte und dass man
als Hamburger plötzlich nicht
Schleswig-Holstein rüberfahren konnte
obwohl das eigentlich gang und gäbe ist
also auch nicht in die angrenzenden auch
nicht an die Elbe irgendwo bei knipse
was ist das für ein Wahnwitz gewesen
oder an der alten musste dann mit der
Maske Joggen jeder Virologe hat von
Anfang an gesagt das ist völliger
Blödsinn das muss nicht sein das müsste
auch aufgearbeitet werden Bücher darüber
inzwischen mir nicht von Querdenken
stammen und sehr substanziell sind eines
heißt möge die ganze Republik mit dem
fingerabdruckhandlung weil ich habe ja
auch aktuell ein Buch geschrieben die
immer kontrollieren wo es liegt und dann
hat das darf ich nicht aber ist auch
okay dann habe ich dann habe ich die
Buchhändlerin angesprochen gehabt und
habe nur gefragt das lag auch gut und
dann hat sie mir über das Buch erzählt
möge die ganze Republik mit dem Finger
auf die zeigen der Spruch stand ja
übrigens vom RTL Berlin
Blume ähm politik-chef ist ja bei RTL
und dann hat mir die Buchhändlerin
erzählt gehabt dass das Buch damals auf
Platz zwei der spiegeliste war und es
durfte nicht eingeräumt werden ich werde
jetzt nicht sagen welche Buchhändlerin
das war und welche Kette das das Regal
der Platz zwei blieb leer nein doch und
das habe ich dann auch auf Twitter
öffentlich gemacht dass ich das erfahren
habe und dann haben wir ganz viele
geschrieben ja sie haben das in der
Buchhandlung gekauft unterm Tresen in
der anderen Buchhandlung wurde panisch
hingeworfen die Frage die ich mir da
Stelle ist sind wir überhaupt schon so
weit dass wir aufarbeiten können oder
ist eigentlich immer noch das auch
Meinungen unterdrückt werden nein wir
können natürlich immer noch aufarbeiten
gott sei Dank gibt es auch die Welt und
die Welt am Sonntag und die Welt online
über das Haus für das wir arbeiten wenn
Sie für Ihren Buch so werden färbe ich
so für meinen Arbeitgeber nein man kann
man kann immer noch aufarbeiten
nein ich meine ist nicht terminiert also
es ist nie zu spät oder was
aufzuarbeiten die Frage ist nur ob es
viel nutzt und ob es hilft eine ähnliche
Entwicklung zu verhindern und da bin ich
das skeptisch aber das mit dem
Buchhandel finde ich erschüttern es gab
übrigens nicht von mir möge die gesamte
republikation
von zwei ganz tüchtigen ordentlichen
klugen Journalisten es hat so ein Fall
vor paar Jahren gegeben mit meiner
Freundin Winter sie haben sich
Buchhändler Buchhändler geweigert das
Buch zu verkaufen weil es politisch dann
Ansichten etliche Buchhändler auch große
Buchhandlungen ich sage jetzt keinen
Namen aber es fängt mit den Hamburgern
mit den in Berlin verhindern ja also was
mich am meisten an der Sache
oder mir die Größen sorgen macht es gab
ein Zitat von Lauterbach wo er sagt das
was wir in der corona-zeit gemacht haben
ähnliche Maßnahmen werden wir auch zum
Klimaschutz anwenden müssen an das Zitat
erinnere ich mich gut und das heißt ich
glaube da nicht an irgendeine Absicht
oder Plan oder Verschwörung da halte ich
überhaupt nichts davon aber das Denken
ist natürlich so bei den Leuten dass sie
sagen wir
wenn wir so große Ziele wenn sie so
große Ziel geht dann müssen wir zu so
drastischen Maßnahmen greifen und ich
glaube Sie haben es schon gesagt äh
Bremer das wir bei den Grünen aber auch
bei der SPD bei vielen in Deutschland
ganz große Mehrheit dafür hätten und das
ist im Grunde genommen das was mir die
größten Sorgen bereitet wir bleiben
einmal auch noch bei dem Eingangstür mit
dem Impfschäden und auch mit dem
impfdruck fanden sie das gerechtfertigt
das 2G und dieser Druck auf Menschen
gemacht wurde sie impfen zu lassen weil
er wirklich von der gesellschaftlichen
Teil aber ausgeschlossen nein fand ich
nicht vorbei ich muss dazu sagen ich
habe nicht zu den Leuten gehört die im
Friedrich sind ich habe mich selbst auch
dreimal impfen lassen ich gehöre
allerdings auch zu denen die
Nebenwirkungen gehabt haben auch nicht
unerhebliche Nebenwirkungen ja bin
trotzdem im Großen und Ganzen also der
Meinung dass es natürlich wissen was sie
hat nicht will sie eigentlich nicht so
persönlich fragen aber auch ja also ich
hatte zum Beispiel Tinnitus hatte ich
auch nie im Leben vorher und das Finger
drei Tage nach der Impfung an und der
dauert auch bis heute an ja und ja dann
hatte ich noch so wie vertiksyndrom was
man normalerweise nach Corona bekommt
das ging danach den Monaten zurück ja
auf einmal zu ganz komischen Zeiten das
ging dann Stück für Stück zurück ist
aber bis heute insofern geblieben dass
nach dem Sport muss ich jetzt immer
erstmal schlafen ja das war vorher nicht
so ich trainiere also seit 45 Jahren wie
man hoffentlich sieht aber das ist also
das ist bis heute so vielleicht liegt
also tatsächlich so dass ich ähm
das ist das das kurz tatsächlich nach
der Impfung an ja und ich überhaupt
keiner der da an ja das Impfen irgendwie
verpönte Gegenteil also ich bin ein
Anhänger davon sich impfen zu lassen ja
klar auch das für die meisten Menschen
die höchste Entscheidung war aber ich
glaube auch dass man offener über die
Schäden sprechen muss ja und das
aufarbeiten muss das ist ja ein bisschen
Problem dass man so eine differenzierte
Meinung dass man da sich eigentlich nur
Feinde macht inzwischen alle Stühle
setzt die einen sagen impfen ist ganz
schrecklich wenn ich impfen lässt dann
bist du ganz schlimm ja und die anderen
sagen ja so rum also ich habe da ein
bisschen Mittelposition zu dem Thema
also wissen sie das ist noch nicht genug
das in der Mittelposition haben obwohl
dieser nach beiden Seiten viel besser
sehen wenn sich die chronologin
Chronologie der Ereignisse angucken ganz
am Anfang ich hier stehe ja den Leuten
zu dass es schwierig war weil es sowas
noch nie gegeben hat seit der seit dem
Spanischen Grippe glaube ich aber es
fing an Maske tragen kann auch ein Schal
sein es musste keine Maske sein
Hände waschen und Abstand halten das hat
sich dann langsam gesteigert
bist du diesem Satz von Herrn Montgomery
wir haben es mit einer
tyranneide ungeimpften zu tun man hat
sofort einen Sündenbock gehabt wissen
sie aus Mangel an den klassischen
Sündenböcken die man nicht mehr
angreifen kann waren jetzt die
ungeimpften Sündenböcke
ein Stück weit dass man nicht versucht
hat also am Anfang besteht man ihn ja zu
sagen okay mit so einer Situation noch
nie jemand konfrontierten ich hätte zu
der Zeit auch kein Politiker sein wollen
dass Du entscheiden
als meiner Sicht war dass man nicht
schnell bemüht war eine guten Datenbasis
zu arbeiten und auch nicht gewillt war
das zu tun und auch sehr schnell einfach
mit mit Fakten Dinge zu belegen man hat
mit Glaubenssätzen Dinge belegt hat an
den festgehalten aus meiner Sicht an
manchen viel zu fest denkt man nur an
die kleinen Schulkinder und an die
Kindergartenkinder auf deren Rücken ganz
viel ausgetragen wurde wo man heute
feststellt es war völlig unnötig was der
gesunde Menschenverstand damals schon
gesagt hat und das kriege ich an da gab
es heute sowas wo sie sagen sie haben zu
wenig nachgefragt selber weil man zeigt
immer auf die Politik aber würden sie
auch heute sagen in der corona-pandemie
haben auch Sie in einer Sache zu wenig
nachgefragt also es gab jetzt bei mir
persönlich schon irgendwann der Punkt wo
es gekippt ist am Anfang ist man gefolgt
war auch stark dabei und und hat hat das
mitgetragen aber es gab dann immer mehr
Widersprüche und auch Dinge wo man mit
einem ich sag's noch mal einen gesunden
Menschenverstand nicht mehr
nachvollziehen konnte nach mich mal
glauben wollte und das war der Punkt wo
man nachgefragt hat recherchiert hat
andere Meinungen gehört hat und dann
auch nicht mehr eigentlich bereit war
den zu folgende gesellschaftliche Druck
war hier und da sehr groß auch im
beruflichen Umfeld
aber der innere Glaube und auch du Wille
der war nicht mehr vorhanden sondern
ganz seltsame Geschichte als ob die
Leute eine solche Katastrophe geradezu
gebraucht hätten
Kanzler scholzpflicht immer vom
unterhaken nicht im Zusammenhang mit
Corona war immer vom Zusammenhalt die
Rede also Frau Merkel mehr geprägt als
mit dem zusammenhalten
das Gefühl etwas wie in die deutsche
Nation kommt wieder ins Leben zurück
müssen voneinander verantwortlich wir
ziehen alle am selben Strang und Herr
Lauterbach ist promoviert ist Doktor ich
meine ich glaube der hat noch keinen
einzigen Tagen sein Leben einen
Blutdruck gemessen von dem würde ich mir
nicht meine beruhigungsspitze geben
lassen also wenn wir die Autorität und
deswegen
der Fehler ist aber ein anderer jemand
der entweder wirklich eine Autorität ist
auf einem bestimmten Fachgebiet oder
sich dafür hält
der ist noch lange kein Politiker ja und
schon gar kein Minister aber wenn
natürlich die öffentliche Meinung
dermaßen überwältigend nicht verstanden
hätte wenn er Lauterbach nicht
Gesundheitsminister wird dann bleibt ihr
als Kanzler kaum was anderes
in jeder komischen Hintergrund
daraus können wir auch was lernen es
kann jemand in seinem Fachgebiet extrem
gut sein trotzdem kann er nicht
politisch nicht unbedingt auch politisch
Denken und Handeln ein Politiker hat
ganz anderes noch im Kopf zu haben
deshalb hätte ich immer gesagt nimm ein
vernünftigen und hol dir Lauterbach als
Berater dazu aber nicht als Minister
damit fing es mal an das zweite was ich
mal loswerden wollte bei aller Kritik
über impfen Impfpflicht kann man so oder
so denken
aber das will überhaupt darüber
diskutiert haben dass wir überhaupt
impfen konnten das ist schon ein
Meisterwerk derjenigen die diesen
Impfstoff entwickelt haben auch wenn es
vor wissen wir ja
Voruntersuchung nicht untersucht das
heißt ja nach
vorforschungsdem man das eben dann
entwickelt hat aber dass das so schnell
ging hat doch keiner ja
Leistung schnell heißt nicht automatisch
gut und wir warten erstmal wir sind aber
gut das ist noch eine große Frage liegt
bei ihren einzuziehen 10000 würden sie
mitgehen beim Meisterwerk kein Mensching
zwischen Bremer und Brother hier sind
gerade ein Graben als Menschen zu Bremer
oder sie sind nicht mitgehen mit dem
Meister der Impfung bitte sie wird nicht
mitgehen bei Meisterwerk der Impfung
würde ich nicht mitgehen es war ein
großer Feldversuch ein Experiment kannst
der Schuld schreibst so sprach einer von
Versuchskaninchen das sind sehr sehr
schöne
be hatte immunologischen virologin sagte
wir haben jetzt ein Experiment in 4
Milliarden Menschen es gab keine
Nebenwirkungen ja im ZDF Morgenmagazin
das kann man alles nachsehen Bruder es
war trotzdem ein Erfolg alle Welt hat
damals gedacht was machen wir gegen
diese verdammte Pandemie gibt es einen
schönen Tag alle Welt guckt immer auf
Deutschland
leider nicht und weil sie nämlich keine
mRNA Impfstoffe akzeptiert haben haben
wir in China die ganze Zeit diese
permanenten lockdowns das wissen wir
nicht wir stellen eine Kausalität hat
ein bisschen darf ich doch wohl auch
noch an Übermittlung von wirklich
angesehenen Blättern und Journalisten
Glauben
unglaublich nein ja das ist der große
Unterschied warum lassen die jetzt
plötzlich zumindest für Ausländer in
China die bei uns im Shop
mal so mal so gesperren ganze Städte ab
und dann machen sie es wieder auf ich
würde mich nicht auf die wissen sie nur
noch
die facheignung war in Deutschland noch
nie ein Kriterium für Berufungen sonst
wäre Frau Lambrecht nicht verteidigt ich
habe ja gerade gesagt dass die doch bei
Lauterbach war es genau das Motiv seine
angebliche fache so kann man sich vertun
ja ja sind wir ja wieder einer Meinung
ich bin nur der Meinung dass es schon
eine Leistung war dass wir in Impfstoff
überhaupt hatten und auch noch einen der
jedenfalls gemessen an anderen selbst an
dem von astrazenegger deutlich
wirkungsvoller waren also ich habe nie
Nebenwirkung gehabt und ich habe glaube
ich fünf Mal die Impfungen auf die
Statistik zurückkomme der letzte
Verteidigungsposition ist dass die
Impfung für milderer Verläufe sorgt ich
kenne dieses Argument und es gibt für
beide Argumente für das Argument Folgen
auf beiden Seiten es gibt Leute die
geimpft sind drei vier fünfmal trotzdem
schwer erkrankt waren und es gibt Leute
die nicht gar kein fremdschutz und es
gab keinen fremdschutz ja wir haben nein
wir sind in diesem Falle da kommen wir
nicht zusammen ja das müssen wir auch
nicht nur das ist nicht nötig nein
schauen sie sind auch nicht gleich alt
es wurde uns versichert dass die Impfung
dass die Impfung vor der Ansteckung
schützt von der Ansteckung durch
irgendwas oder auch gegenüber einem doch
natürlich das war das Logo es gab
Werbeplakate dafür nein
immer gesagt worden dass es für mildere
Verläufe sorgen aber nicht unbedingt vor
Ansteckung doch
Ansteckung das möchte ich meiner Archiv
hier haben habe ich leider nicht
okay
soweit könnten sie mir schon glauben
wirklich nein das ist nicht durchgängig
überhaupt
auch eingespielt ähm die den Film das am
Anfang zwei geh schon auch damit ja
argumentiert wurde das fremdschutz
besteht das hat sich aber irgendwann
schon geändert also da haben wir beide
alles wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie